Florida is crucial this election. Florida, Florida, Florida. One of the people who thinks about that a lot is Kevin Sheekey. He's the guy whose job it is to spend $100 million that billionaire Mike Bloomberg has devoted to winning Florida for Joe Biden.
佛罗里达州在这次选举中至关重要。佛罗里达，佛罗里达，还是佛罗里达。凯文·希基（Kevin Sheekey）是对此深感忧虑的人之一。他的工作就是负责花掉亿万富翁迈克·布隆伯格（Mike Bloomberg）承诺的1亿美元，助力乔·拜登（Joe Biden）拿下佛罗里达州。
Sheekey is not intimidated by that task at all. He's spent lots of Bloomberg's money in the past. He ran Bloomberg's three successful runs for New York mayor and his campaign for president this year.
希基对这项任务一点也不感到胆怯。过去他曾挥霍过布隆伯格的大量资金。他曾管理过布隆伯格三次成功的纽约市长竞选，以及他今年参加的总统竞选。
And Mike likes to say he gave me an unlimited budget, and I exceeded it each and every time. I actually don't intend to do that in the state of Florida.
迈克喜欢说他给了我无限预算，而我每次都超支了。但我其实没打算在佛罗里达州这么做。
So why Florida? Of all the battleground states, why $100 million there? Kevin explained that a big part of it has to do with what's going to happen in other states. He pointed to all the times, in tweets and in speeches, that the president has said that mail-in ballots cannot be trusted.
那么为什么要选佛罗里达？在所有的摇摆州中，为什么要在那儿投入1亿美元？凯文解释说，很大一部分原因与在其他州将要发生的事情有关。他指出了总统在推特和演讲中多次声称邮寄选票不可信的事实。
Donald Trump has sought to delegitimatize all mail-in ballots, full stop. And clearly, will have a plan to contest those ballots after election day, as they are counted, in important swing states such as Michigan and Pennsylvania, which Joe Biden is currently leading in.
唐纳德·特朗普试图全面否定所有邮寄选票。显然，他会有一个计划，在选举日之后计票时，对密歇根州和宾夕法尼亚州等乔·拜登目前领先的重要摇摆州的这些选票提出质疑。
Michigan will take at least three days to count their ballots. Pennsylvania is not much different.
密歇根州至少需要三天来统计选票。宾夕法尼亚州的情况也差不多。
Trump has said, listen, I'm going to take every lawyer and every judge I have. I'm going to question every single ballot and try to toss them out. And just throwing out ballots by random could really move those states from Biden to Trump.
特朗普说，听着，我会动用我所有的律师和法官。我要对每一张选票提出质疑，并试图废掉它们。随便废除选票真的可能让这些州从拜登的优势转变为特朗普的优势。
That's because more Democrats are doing mail-in ballots than Republicans are this year. Bloomberg's people have actually run the numbers and calculated that there are states who were throwing out 7% of the ballots at random for not being filled out correctly, which would flip a Biden victory in that state to a Trump victory.
这是因为今年使用邮寄选票的民主党人比共和党人多。布隆伯格的团队实际上计算过数据，发现有些州随机废除了7%因填写不正确而无效的选票，这足以将该州拜登的胜利扭转为特朗普的胜利。
And that's a very dangerous proposition. And that's what we're trying to avoid by getting into Florida.
这是一个非常危险的提议。而这正是我们试图通过进驻佛罗里达来避免的事情。
Florida is a state that Donald Trump pretty much has to win. If he loses Florida, it would be enormously difficult for him to gather enough electoral votes to have re-election. And-- this is key-- Florida is a state that counts mail-in ballots as they arrive. They're counting them right now, already, which means we very well could know the results in Florida on election night. And if Florida goes to Biden, it might settle the race that night.
佛罗里达是唐纳德·特朗普几乎必须赢下的州。如果他输掉了佛罗里达，他想要获得足够的选举人票以实现连任将极其困难。而且——这一点很关键——佛罗里达州在收到邮寄选票时就开始计票了。他们现在就已经在统计了，这意味着我们在选举之夜很可能就知道佛罗里达的选举结果。如果佛罗里达归了拜登，那晚的选战可能就此尘埃落定。
And our ultimate goal is to win the state of Florida so that we, quite frankly, don't have to have that fight in a state like Pennsylvania.
我们最终的目标是赢得佛罗里达州，这样说实话，我们就不必在宾夕法尼亚州那样的地方陷入苦战。
So how did you pick 100 million? What was that discussion like?
那你怎么选定了1亿这个数字？当时的讨论是怎样的？
You know, listen, I think it was ultimately what we determined we would need. It was the number that we thought we would make a difference.
你知道，听着，我认为这最终是我们认定所需要的金额。这是我们认为能产生影响的数字。
I called a guy who I know who is probably the smartest strategist on the Democratic side. And I asked him, how much would you need to spend if you wanted to be able to have an impact on a race, statewide race, in a presidential in Florida? And how much would you need to really put your thumb on the scale?
我打电话给一位我认识的，大概是民主党阵营里最聪明的战略家。我问他，如果你想在佛罗里达州的总统竞选中，在全州范围的选战中产生影响，你需要花多少钱？你需要花多少钱才能真正起到决定性的推动作用？
And he said at the time, well, Florida is an extraordinarily expensive state. It has a lot of large, expensive media markets. And to have any sort of impact, you really need to spend $20 million. And if you really want to put your thumb on the scale, you're going to need to spend $70 million. And so, this being Bloomberg, we rounded up.
他当时说，嗯，佛罗里达是一个极其昂贵的州。它有很多大型且昂贵的媒体市场。想要产生任何影响，你至少得花2000万美元。如果你真的想发挥关键影响力，你需要花7000万美元。所以，鉴于这是布隆伯格，我们向上取整了。
Most of that Bloomberg money is going to TV ads and digital ads, dropped into cities all across the state, like a vast air war conducted from 30,000 feet. Kevin Sheekey says Bloomberg's doing daily polling to see what effect this is having, which is actually kind of hard to figure out. All kinds of things push voter opinion around.
布隆伯格大部分的钱都投向了电视广告和数字广告，像一场从3万英尺高空发动的空中战役，洒向全州各地的城市。凯文·希基表示，布隆伯格正在进行每日民调，以观察这产生了什么效果，但这其实很难判定。各种各样的事情都会影响选民的看法。
But Kevin says the numbers in Florida have moved from a tie between Trump and Biden to a small Biden lead. It's still within the margin of error, but it's a lead, 2 to 4 points, that the Bloomberg people find encouraging.
但凯文说，佛罗里达的民调数字已经从特朗普和拜登的平局，变成了拜登的微弱领先。虽然仍在误差范围内，但这2到4个百分点的领先优势让布隆伯格的团队感到振奋。
So that's the view from 30,000 feet. Down on the ground, that all looks a little different because of something so basic. And that's the coronavirus and how the two campaigns have responded to the coronavirus.
这就是从3万英尺高空看到的景象。但在地面上，由于一件非常基本的事情，一切看起来就不太一样了。那就是新冠病毒，以及两个竞选阵营对新冠病毒的反应方式。
As you may know over the summer, the Democratic Party policy was, do not go door to door. Do not hold events in person. Do not hold rallies. Republicans did all that stuff.
如你所知，整个夏天，民主党的政策是：不要挨家挨户敲门。不要举行线下活动。不要举行集会。而共和党人把这些事全做了。
And in Florida, even before the virus, they were doing more and registering more voters than the Democrats. In sheer numbers, there are more registered Democrats in the state than Republicans. But since 2016, the Republicans have knocked that lead down. It used to be 7%. Now it's just 3 and 1/2%. A quarter of the voters in the state have no party affiliation.
在佛罗里达州，甚至在病毒出现之前，他们的登记选民工作就比民主党做得多。按绝对数量计算，州内的注册民主党人比共和党人多。但自2016年以来，共和党人缩小了这一差距。曾经领先7%，现在只剩下3.5%。州内有四分之一的选民没有任何党派倾向。
So the Republicans were going strong before the virus. And after the virus hit the state, they resumed normal operations. But the Democrats were not going out to campaign. It was like one party was out there in the streets, visible. And the other was just not.
所以共和党人在疫情前就势头强劲。疫情席卷该州后，他们恢复了正常运作。但民主党人没有出去竞选。就像其中一个政党在街头上清晰可见，而另一个却完全不见踪影。
One of our producers, Lina Misitzis, has been talking to Florida Democrats about all that. And Lina, how are they feeling?
我们的制片人之一，莉娜·米西齐斯（Lina Misitzis），一直在和佛罗里达州的民主党人谈论这些。莉娜，他们的感觉如何？
Not great. Or at least, not the ones that I talked to.
不太好。至少我谈过的人感觉不太好。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
OK, so there's this one voter I found, Marji Hope. She's in a suburb called Weston, which is in one of the bluest counties in Florida. It's Broward County, which is just north of Miami. But she says that the Republican presence is so much more noticeable that her house is somehow surrounded by Trump signs.
好吧，我发现了一位叫马吉·霍普（Marji Hope）的选民。她住在韦斯顿（Weston）的一个郊区，那是佛罗里达州最支持民主党的县之一。是布劳沃德县（Broward County），就在迈阿密北边。但她说，共和党的存在感明显得多，她家周围不知怎么全被特朗普的标语包围了。
Wow.
哇。
And there's almost no Biden signs in her neighborhood.
而且她住处附近几乎没有拜登的标语。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah, and she sees Trump supporters everywhere.
是的，她到处都能看到特朗普的支持者。
The frustrating thing that is happening is when I get texts from my friends with pictures saying, oh my god, a carload of Trump supporters just got out in my neighborhood, and they're knocking on doors right now. But we have been not able to do that.
让人沮丧的是，当我的朋友发短信给我，附上照片说，“天哪，一车特朗普支持者刚在我家附近下车，他们正在敲门”。但我们却无法做到这一点。
So four years ago, Hillary Clinton's campaign had an office near Marji's house in Weston. And that's where people would go to pick up signs, to phone bank, to meet up with each other.
四年前，希拉里·克林顿的竞选团队在马吉韦斯顿的家附近有一个办公室。人们会去那里领取标语、进行电话拉票、彼此会面。
Biden doesn't even have offices set up yet here, OK? We haven't been able to-- we haven't gotten campaign material. I mean, how hard is it to just put stuff on somebody's door? We could get Weston done. There's, like, 65,000 people living here. We could get them done in a weekend. And that's where the frustration is, is the minute we would put a call out, I know that I'd get a ton of people to come out. Because we're all dying to do this.
拜登在这里甚至还没有设立办公室，好吗？我们还没能拿到竞选材料。我是说，往别人门上放点东西有多难？我们完全可以搞定韦斯顿。这里有6.5万居民。我们周末就能搞定。这就是挫败感所在，只要我们发个号召，我知道会有一大群人出来。因为我们都迫不及待地想做这些。
Not only is Marji keeping track of what her site isn't doing, she's keeping track of what the other side is doing. She actually signed up for her county-- the Broward County local Republican newsletter.
马吉不仅在关注自己的一方没在做什么，她也在跟踪另一方在做什么。她甚至注册了她所在县——布劳沃德县当地共和党的通讯。
Wait, why?
等等，为什么？
Because every day, when it sends out its daily email that lists all of the campaign events that they have coming up for the Republicans, she likes to keep track of it. And it kind of drives her crazy, just noticing all of these events that they're running.
因为每天当他们发送列出共和党即将举行的所有竞选活动的每日电子邮件时，她喜欢跟踪这些信息。而这让她有点抓狂，因为她注意到了他们正在开展的所有这些活动。
They are doing candidate forums. They are doing watch parties for the debates. They had watch parties at this place my husband and I used to go have breakfast at all the time, which we're not going to anymore. Because I'm like, if they're hosting these huge watch-- I could send you all these pictures of these people at the debates. Probably fit a lot of young people--
他们正在举行候选人论坛。他们正在举行辩论观看派对。他们在我丈夫和我以前经常去吃早餐的地方举办观看派对，我们现在再也不去了。因为我想，如果他们在举办这种大型观看活动——我可以发给你所有这些他们在辩论现场的照片。可能塞进了许多年轻人——
They make a lot of noise, and they make their presence known.
他们制造了很大的动静，让人们知道他们的存在。
I also talked to Marji's friend, Julie. She tracks the Republican events, too. And while Marji sounds kind of indignant when she talks about it, Julie sounds almost wistful.
我还和马吉的朋友朱莉聊了聊。她也追踪共和党的活动。虽然马吉谈到这些时听起来有些愤慨，但朱莉听起来近乎渴望。
They had pictures on the community Facebook page, and they had a watch party. And I thought, well, that's nice. I mean, most of them weren't wearing masks. So I know that that's something that a lot of people would be hesitant to do.
他们在社区Facebook页面上有照片，他们举行了观看派对。我想，嗯，那很好。我是说，他们中大多数人没戴口罩。所以我知道那是很多人会犹豫去做的事情。
But it just seemed like it was something that involved community, that they were sitting together around, going, hey, we are a group. We are here. And they kind of support each other. And it's kind of something that I wish we could replicate and were as strong.
但这看起来就像是一种涉及社区的事情，他们坐在一起，说，嘿，我们是一个团体。我们在这里。他们互相支持。这就是我希望我们也能复制并做到一样强大的地方。
In the absence of their own official meetups, I found a bunch of frustrated Democrats all over Florida, not just in Broward, who took matters into their own hands.
在没有官方聚会的情况下，我在佛罗里达各地发现了许多沮丧的民主党人，不仅仅是在布劳沃德，他们自己采取了行动。
What are they doing?
他们都在做什么？
OK, there's a woman in Oviedo, which is a small red town. And she's been hosting these very small rallies on street corners every Monday, Wednesday, and Friday.
好吧，奥维耶多（Oviedo）有一个女人，那是个红色小镇。她每周一、周三和周五都会在街角举行非常小型的集会。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
Another example is a grandmother in Tallahassee who told me that she printed out a bunch of Florida voter registration forms. And she was handing them out to young-seeming people in the Walmart parking lot.
另一个例子是塔拉哈西（Tallahassee）的一位祖母，她告诉我她打印了一堆佛罗里达选民登记表。她在沃尔玛的停车场把它们发给看起来很年轻的人。
Now I've read that the Biden campaign did finally start going door to door in Florida and in other states, too, this fall.
但我读到过拜登竞选团队今年秋天终于开始在佛罗里达和其他州挨家挨户敲门了。
Yes, that happened two weeks after I started talking to Marji. And she went out with them. But for her, it wasn't enough.
是的，那是在我开始和马吉谈话两周后发生的。她和他们一起出去了。但对她来说，这还不够。
Why am I canvassing 23 days before-- whatever-- 25 days before an election? I should have been canvassing 40 days before an election.
我为什么要在大选前23天——不管怎样——大选前25天拉票？我应该在大选前40天就开始拉票的。
Right.
对。
You know how many people-- I mean, hundreds of thousands of people have already voted in Florida.
你知道有多少人——我是说，佛罗里达已经有几十万人投过票了。
Well, today on our show, we have stories of people fretting, worried about what is going to happen next, and all that is still unknown. The future is barreling towards them. They're going to find out soon enough, but not quite yet. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And let's get to it. Act 1, the School of Hard Knocks.
好吧，今天在我们的节目中，我们要讲述人们焦虑的故事，担心接下来会发生什么，而一切仍然未知。未来正在疾驰而来。他们很快就会知道结果，但还不是现在。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。让我们开始吧。第一幕，社会大学。
So Lina looked into whether the fears that she heard from Florida's Democrats are justified. Are their leaders dropping the ball? Did the party pull back too far with the coronavirus precautions? She put together this story.
所以莉娜调查了她从佛罗里达民主党人那里听到的担忧是否合理。他们的领导人是否在失职？该政党是否在新冠疫情的预防措施上做得太过了？她制作了这个故事。
I think Democrats have been doing, instead of door knocking, phone calling. And gone is the camaraderie of organizing, everyone breathing in the same air in some makeshift, fluorescent-lit campaign center. This volunteering is done from home. And here's what it looks like.
我想民主党人一直在做的不是敲门，而是打电话。组织工作的友情消失了，每个人都在临时搭建、荧光灯闪烁的竞选中心呼吸着同样的空气。这种志愿工作是在家里完成的。这就是它的样子。
Maria is a phone banking volunteer. She's 33, living in Southeast Florida with her husband and her three-year-old son.
玛丽亚是一名电话拉票志愿者。她33岁，和丈夫及三岁大的儿子住在佛罗里达东南部。
Your entry does not match our records. Please enter your PIN, then pound.
您的输入与我们的记录不符。请输入您的密码，然后按井号键。
She works in consulting. And after work, she has 45 minutes to phone bank before her kid gets home.
她在做咨询工作。下班后，她有45分钟时间在孩子回家前进行电话拉票。
You are now connected.
您现在已接通。
Maria was born in Colombia, moved here when she was 16 with her parents. She's a citizen now, and not a fan of the president.
玛丽亚出生在哥伦比亚，16岁时随父母搬到这里。她现在是公民，不喜欢总统。
His comments against immigrants, against women-- I mean, I think almost every single position that he's taken and every comment that he's made is against what I believe and what I think this country stands for.
他对移民、对女性的评论——我是说，我认为他采取的几乎每一个立场和他做出的每一个评论，都违背了我所相信的以及我认为这个国家所代表的东西。
Maria did door knocking in 2016, and she's doing phone banking now. I wanted her to compare them for me. And so I listened in while she phone banked. In 45 minutes, she dialed 28 phone numbers.
玛丽亚在2016年做过敲门工作，她现在在做电话拉票。我想让她为我比较一下它们。于是我旁听了她电话拉票的过程。在45分钟里，她拨打了28个电话号码。
Hi, is this Angie?
嗨，是安吉吗？
At the tone, please record your message. When you finish recording, you may--
在听到提示音后，请录下您的留言。当您录音完成时，您可以——
Nine of those 28 phone calls went to voicemail, which the Democrats mostly don't think it's worth it to leave messages after the beep. One phone call, a toddler picked up.
在这28个电话中，有9个转入了语音信箱，而民主党人大多认为在哔声后留言不值得。有一个电话是一个蹒跚学步的孩子接的。
Hi, is this Caitlin?
嗨，是凯特琳吗？
Yeah.
是。
The kiddo seemed to put the phone down and walk away.
孩子似乎放下电话走开了。
Hello?
喂？
Some grownups didn't want to get into it either.
有些成年人也不想谈论这个。
With who?
跟谁？
With the Democratic Party of Florida.
跟佛罗里达州民主党。
OK, thank you. Not interested.
好的，谢谢。没兴趣。
All right, thank you.
好的，谢谢。
Of course, not everyone Maria spoke to favored her side.
当然，玛丽亚交谈的对象并非都支持她这一方。
I'm going to vote for Trump.
我要投给特朗普。
Oh, you will?
哦，你会吗？
I'm voting for Trump!
我要投给特朗普！
OK.
好的。
I can tell you that right now.
我现在就可以告诉你。
Bye.
再见。
There were three calls like that.
有三个这样的电话。
I don't think I want to vote for Sleepy Joe. I'm sorry. I don't think he's worth being president.
我想我不想投给“瞌睡乔”。抱歉。我不认为他配当总统。
Thank you.
谢谢。
The goal of these calls, it's not to persuade anyone. It's just to get Biden voters to vote. And over a third of them, 11 people, were Biden supporters. Six of them said that they'd already mailed in their ballots. And five of them hadn't.
这些电话的目的不是说服任何人。只是为了让拜登的支持者投票。而在他们之中，有超过三分之一，即11人是拜登的支持者。其中6人说他们已经邮寄了选票。还有5人没有。
Well, it's only the first week of October. They don't vote until November 3rd. I thought maybe I could send it out at the end of the month.
嗯，这只是十月的第一个星期。他们直到11月3日才投票。我想也许我可以等到月底再寄出。
No, don't wait till the end of the month, because a lot of people are going to be mailing their ballots. And the Postal Service is going to be overwhelmed with the ballots. So make sure you send it in sooner. You don't want to have it delayed and not being counted.
不，不要等到月底，因为很多人都会寄送选票。邮政服务会被选票淹没。所以一定要尽快寄出。你不想让它延迟而导致无法计票。
OK.
好的。
Use black ink, sign the outside of the envelope, and mail it back quickly.
用黑色墨水笔，在信封外面签名，然后尽快寄回。
OK.
好的。
Maria says that that one call, it made it feel worth her time that day.
玛丽亚说那个电话让她觉得当天的时间花得值。
Because I think that was one more vote-- one vote that will be counted and wouldn't have been otherwise if I hadn't called him.
因为我认为那是又多了一票——如果我没给他打电话，这一票就不会被统计进去。
All right, have a good night.
好的，祝你有美好的一晚。
Bye.
再见。
So 45 minutes, one actual vote for her team, for her state. Though, also, four other Biden voters that she nudged towards mailing in their ballots.
所以45分钟，为她的团队，为她的州争取到了一张实际的选票。尽管还有其他四位拜登选民被她推动去邮寄选票。
And how do these phone calls compare to door knocking? Maria says in 2016, in terms of how many people she'd made direct contact with in a shift, door knocking and phone banking are about the same. But going door to door takes way more time.
那么这些电话与敲门相比如何？玛丽亚说，在2016年，就她在一次班次中直接接触的人数而言，敲门和电话拉票差不多。但挨家挨户敲门花费的时间要多得多。
Between going and grabbing the list and getting to the place and walking around and waiting-- someone's mom would open the door, and then we had to wait for the person that we were actually trying to reach to come over.
在获取名单、到达目的地、走动、等待的过程中——别人的妈妈开了门，然后我们不得不等我们真正试图联系的人走过来。
What happened yesterday took 45 minutes, and then what you're-- like, a Saturday afternoon in 2016, it sounds like it would take a few hours.
昨天发生的事情只花了45分钟，而2016年一个周六下午的情况听起来需要几个小时。
Yeah, but I do think it's just as good.
是的，但我确实认为它同样有效。
There's been actual research on this, which shows that door knocking and phone banking are pretty close in terms of their effectiveness, with a slight edge towards door knocking, though calling people is faster.
对此有实际的研究，表明敲门和电话拉票在有效性方面相当接近，敲门略占优势，尽管打电话更快。
So the question really is, how many phone calls are Democrats making for Biden in Florida, compared to doors knocked on in the past? I called around for numbers. The closest I got was from the independent organization that coordinates a lot of the get-out-the-vote among Democrats in Florida. They're called America Votes.
所以问题实际上是，与过去敲门的数量相比，民主党人为拜登在佛罗里达打了多少电话？我到处询问数据。我得到的最接近的数据来自一个协调佛罗里达民主党人拉票工作的独立组织。他们叫“美国投票”（America Votes）。
They say when you count phone banking and door knocking and everything else that they do to reach voters, they've doubled the number of people they've had conversations with in Florida. It's 2 million this year versus 1 million or fewer in previous elections.
他们说，当你把电话拉票、敲门以及他们为联系选民所做的一切加在一起时，他们在佛罗里达进行谈话的人数翻了一番。今年是200万人，而在之前的选举中是100万或更少。
But that number doesn't include the Democratic Party's own get-out-the-vote effort, which is an important part of the picture. Party officials would not give me outreach numbers for this year or previous elections.
但这个数字不包括民主党自己获取选票的努力，这是图景的重要组成部分。党内官员不愿给我今年的联系人数或之前的选举人数。
What they did do, instead, is say that everything is on track. All of the Florida Democratic officials I talked to agreed on that. Here's Debbie Wasserman Schultz. She's Marji's congresswoman, and she used to chair the National Democratic Party.
他们所做的是说一切都在正轨上。我谈过的所有佛罗里达民主党官员都同意这一点。这是黛比·沃瑟曼·舒尔茨（Debbie Wasserman Schultz）。她是马吉的国会女议员，曾担任全国民主党主席。
I mean, at the moment, I can tell you that we lead. I mean, the proof is in the voting. Democrats lead Republicans in vote by mail by 360,000-plus vote by mail ballots being turned in. That is just massive, massive increases. We are really lapping the field. And so what I say to nervous Democrats is, the proof is in the voting. And we have to just keep people voting.
我是说，目前，我可以告诉你我们处于领先地位。我是说，证据就在投票中。在邮寄选票方面，民主党以36万多张选票领先于共和党。那是非常巨大的增幅。我们确实遥遥领先。所以我对紧张的民主党人说的是，证据在投票中。我们只需要让人们继续投票。
It's true that more Democrats than Republicans have mailed in their ballots. But that's kind of what you'd expect. COVID reactions have fallen along party lines, and way more Democrats asked for mail-in ballots than Republicans did.
确实，邮寄选票的民主党人比共和党人多。但这正是你所预料到的。对新冠疫情的反应是按照党派划分的，申请邮寄选票的民主党人远多于共和党人。
Of course, things could get completely reshuffled on Monday. That's when early in-person voting starts in Florida. Republicans could start showing up in droves.
当然，周一可能会彻底洗牌。那是佛罗里达州开始面对面提前投票的时间。共和党人可能会开始成群结队地出现。
I honestly think that there's nothing Debbie Wasserman Schultz or other party leaders could say that would reassure Marji or Julie or any of the nervous Democrats I talked to. Jeff Green, who also lives in Broward, he remembers, two years ago, how confidently they all headed into the governor's race. It was the race that was supposed to show that a Democrat could win statewide office in Florida.
我诚实地认为，黛比·沃瑟曼·舒尔茨或其他党内领导人说的话都无法安慰马吉或朱莉，或任何我交谈过的紧张的民主党人。同样住在布劳沃德的杰夫·格林（Jeff Green）记得，两年前，他们所有人是多么自信地投入州长选举。那是本应显示民主党可以在佛罗里达赢得州级职位的竞选。
So two years ago today, Andrew Gillum was up 9 points against Ron DeSantis in the governor's race. And all the Democrats were, ra, ra, ra, Gillum's going to win. And of course, he didn't.
两年前的今天，安德鲁·吉勒姆（Andrew Gillum）在州长竞选中对罗恩·德桑蒂斯（Ron DeSantis）领先9个百分点。所有的民主党人都在喊，加油，吉勒姆要赢了。当然，他没有赢。
Looming even bigger, of course, is Hillary Clinton. Every Democrat I talked to invoked Hillary Clinton.
当然，更引人注目的是希拉里·克林顿。我交谈过的每一个民主党人都援引了希拉里·克林顿。
We all remember. We all remember what happened in 2016. We remember what happened in 2018. We remember all of it. And so nobody trusts it anymore.
我们都记得。我们都记得2016年发生了什么。我们记得2018年发生了什么。我们记得所有这些。所以没人再信任它了。
Fact is, most big elections in Florida in the last 10 years have been decided by about 1.1% of the vote. Biden's ahead right now in the polls, but not by much. And either candidate could win. So they're not wrong to be worried.
事实是，过去10年佛罗里达的大型选举大多由约1.1%的选票决定。拜登目前在民调中领先，但优势不大。任何候选人都有可能获胜。所以他们担心并非没有道理。
Lina Misitzis is one of the producers of our show.
莉娜·米西齐斯是我们节目的制片人之一。
Coming up, fears of toys that come on without anybody touching them and other worries that have nothing at all to do with electoral politics, I promise. That is in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，关于没人碰就会自己启动的玩具的恐惧，以及其他与选举政治完全无关的担忧，我保证。一分钟后，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Moment After This Moment. We have stories today of people who are worrying about a future that is on its way. We are now at Act 2 of our program. Act 2, Words Versus Fear.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《那一刻之后》。我们今天讲述关于担心即将到来的未来的人们的故事。我们现在进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，文字与恐惧。
So when you're scared about things that might happen, the most effective thing to do, of course, is to jump into action and see that things go your way, right? To try to make things happen so that the worst does not occur. But the truth is, that doesn't always do the job, right? It doesn't always get rid of your fears. So then what do you do?
所以，当你害怕可能会发生的事情时，最有效的做法当然是采取行动，确保事情朝着你想要的方向发展，对吧？努力让事情发生，以免最坏的情况出现。但事实是，这并不总能奏效，对吧？它并不总能消除你的恐惧。那么你该怎么办？
Well, years ago, we did a story about somebody who came up with this strategy. There were things that this guy was afraid of, things that put him on edge. And one day, he just decided to write them down, just to get them out of his system. And so he started writing, numbering every fear, one after another. Quickly, it got to 10 fears, and then 20, and then 30 and 40 and 50, until he had 138 of them on paper.
嗯，多年前，我们做过一个关于某个人想出这个策略的故事。这个家伙害怕一些事情，一些让他紧张的事情。有一天，他决定把它们写下来，只是为了把它们从脑海中排解出去。于是他开始书写，一个接一个地给每个恐惧编号。很快，到了10个恐惧，然后20个、30个、40个、50个，直到他在纸上列了138个。
The man's name is Michael Bernard Loggins. He was in his 50s at the time he did this. He's developmentally disabled. He was living in San Francisco-- still does. And the arts program for adults where he did this, a place called Creativity Explored, published this writing as a little, handwritten, xeroxed zine called Fears of Your Life.
这个人的名字叫迈克尔·伯纳德·洛金斯（Michael Bernard Loggins）。他写下这些时已经50多岁了。他有发育障碍。他住在旧金山——现在依然住在那里。他从事创作的成人艺术项目，一个叫“创意探索”（Creativity Explored）的地方，将这些文字作为一份小型、手写、复印的小册子出版，题为《你生活中的恐惧》（Fears of Your Life）。
And then a few years later, Michael found out there were more fears to tame by turning them into words, and he put out a part 2, a sequel, titled Fears of Your Life, a Whole Brand New One. This one listed 45 fears.
几年后，迈克尔发现通过把恐惧变成文字可以驯服更多的恐惧，他推出了第二部分，即续集，题为《你生活中的恐惧，全新的一个》。这本列出了45个恐惧。
Michael gave us permission to excerpt the two books. And they're just this remarkable, wide-ranging, encyclopedic, Talmudic, memorable tour of human fears. And none of them have to do with politics. And they seem worth going back to today. Actor Tom Wright is our reader.
迈克尔允许我们摘录这两本书。它们是一场关于人类恐惧的非凡、广泛、百科全书式、塔木德式、令人难忘的巡礼。它们没有一个与政治有关。而且它们在今天似乎值得回顾。演员汤姆·赖特（Tom Wright）是我们的读者。
Fear of hospitals and needles. Fear of school and dentists. Fear of noises and bumps in the middle of the night. Fear of doors when they slams. Fear of toys that come on by itself without anyone touching it.
对医院和针头的恐惧。对学校和牙医的恐惧。对半夜的声音和撞击声的恐惧。对门砰砰关上的恐惧。对玩具没人碰自己启动的恐惧。
Fear of being caught with another woman after cheating on your wife. Fear of being in wrong places at the wrong time. Fear of dropping your soda as it hit the ground and fizz on you. Fear of tall giraffe. Fear of some birds. Fear of being different.
对出轨被抓的恐惧。对在错误的时间出现在错误地点的恐惧。对苏打水掉到地上溅到你的恐惧。对高长颈鹿的恐惧。对某些鸟类的恐惧。对与众不同的恐惧。
I fear that those TV people would take off my favorite cartoon, The Rugrats, off the air and wouldn't be able to watch them anymore for a long, long, long time. Please let well enough alone. Please don't take my Rugrats cartoon off the air because I love that cartoon. Let there be a possibility that life with the Rugrats stays put, means leave my Rugrats cartoon on TV, Michael said.
我害怕那些电视人会把我会喜欢的卡通片《小淘气》（The Rugrats）停播，那样我就再也不能看它们很久很久很久了。请保持原样。请不要把我的《小淘气》动画片停播，因为我爱那部卡通片。让《小淘气》的生活留下的可能性存在吧，意味着把我《小淘气》的动画片留在电视上，迈克尔说。
Fear if you put things that doesn't belongs in your ears, and you bust the drums that's are in your ears. It liable to run you deaf, where you can't hear anything at all. You wouldn't be able to hear cars when they're coming at you. That can be a frightening and very horrible situation to happen to you if you had an occurrence in real life, especially if you comes involved in it. Can you get hit by cars if you can't hear them?
如果你把不该放的东西放进耳朵里，你会弄破耳朵里的耳膜。这可能会让你变聋，什么都听不见。当汽车向你开来时，你听不到它们。如果你在现实生活中发生这种情况，尤其如果你卷入其中，那可能是一种可怕且非常糟糕的情况。如果你听不到它们，你会被汽车撞吗？
Michael is afraid and frightening and fearful when Andrea Scheer goes away for a very, very, very long, long, long, long vacational trips in order to go traveling all over the world, almost like different places and different cities and countries to visit people in her own image and own language. He afraid Andrea Scheer would come back to San Francisco, California with all different accents and won't be able to speak Michael's English, or not be able to understand his words that he's telling her, like "Merry Christmas."
迈克尔在安德烈娅·谢尔（Andrea Scheer）为了去世界各地旅行而进行非常、非常、非常漫长的假期旅行时感到害怕和恐惧，几乎就像去不同的地方、不同的城市和国家访问不同形象和语言的人。他害怕安德烈娅·谢尔会带着各种不同的口音回到加利福尼亚州旧金山，无法说迈克尔的英语，或无法理解他告诉她的词，比如“圣诞快乐”。
I'm afraid and fearful that pigeons don't know right from wrong to not go out into the street. They don't have the kind of memory as we humans does to know what to do and what shalt not do. They must don't know the danger of their lives are being jeopardized. And they must don't know what can definitely happen to them to humans' knowledges and sense. They land just anywhere they can find a land-on surface.
我害怕且恐惧鸽子不知道是非好坏，不知道不要走到街上去。它们不像我们人类那样拥有记忆力来知道该做什么和不该做什么。它们肯定不知道自己的生命危在旦夕。它们肯定不知道对于人类的知识和感知来说会发生什么。它们就在能找到表面的任何地方着陆。
Fear of sharks. Fear of giant man. Fear of gorilla. Fear of Godzilla. Fear of tall woman. Fear of killer whales. Fear of dinosaurs bird. Fear of invisible man. Fear of blob.
对鲨鱼的恐惧。对巨人的恐惧。对大猩猩的恐惧。对哥斯拉的恐惧。对高女人的恐惧。对虎鲸的恐惧。对恐龙鸟的恐惧。对隐形人的恐惧。对水滴怪的恐惧。
Fear that if I go into the library and I happens to get, like, seven or eight books, and I happens to find a place in the library, that I would get a lot of comfortable and begin reading in those seven or eight books, but one book at a time, and I start to read, and somehow, my voice and mind start to get from low to high and thinking that there weren't anyone elses reading theirs. And I look over and the people in the library and I get fearful, and I'll say, "Oops, sorry."
害怕如果我去图书馆恰好拿到七八本书，恰好在图书馆里找个地方，我会很舒服地开始阅读这七八本书，但是一次读一本，我开始读，不知怎么的，我的声音和思想开始从低变高，觉得没有其他人正在读他们的。我抬头看了一眼图书馆里的人，我感到害怕，我会说：“哎呀，对不起。”
If your friends are people that you are with and you hear them making decision about what they decided that they are going to steal expensive and very valuable merchandise out of the department stores and don't care less, you say, "I am out of here. Bye bye. I'm not getting caught in your crazy schemes. I'm not your stealer partner. I'm just your friend. It's going to trouble, and it's on your head, not mine. I'm not going to participate in stealing with you, so leave me out of your crazy schemes, especially if it involve Oreo cookies and other stuff, hot stuff." Fear of me getting in trouble just as well.
如果你的朋友是你在一起的人，而你听到他们做出决定，决定要在百货商店偷昂贵且非常有价值的商品，而且不在乎，你会说：“我走了。拜拜。我不会陷入你们的疯狂计划中。我不是你们的偷窃合伙人。我只是你们的朋友。这是自找麻烦，这是你们的问题，不是我的。我不打算参与你们的偷窃，所以把我也排除在你们的疯狂计划之外，特别是如果它涉及奥利奥饼干和其他东西，那种热门商品。” 害怕我也陷入麻烦。
It's very scary and fearfully to be sleeping in your bed in the middle of the night whenever there is a telephone right beside the bed on your left near the door you once enter and exit out. You are sleeping. The telephone rang and scare the living life out of you in the middle of the night. Who is this calling at this hour of the night?
半夜睡觉时，不管什么时候，如果你进入和离开的门旁边，左边床头正好有个电话，那是很可怕且恐惧的。你正在睡觉。电话响了，在半夜把你吓得魂飞魄散。谁会在这种半夜时分打电话？
Fear of a blasted music on the radio when you are not aware that the volume is turned up. Fear of rolling downhill backwards. Fear of foghorn. Fear of getting hugged by somebody you don't like. There's Los Angeles fears. Fear of getting hit over the head when you carry lots of dough with you, or bucks.
害怕收音机里突然放出震耳欲聋的音乐，当你没意识到音量被调大时。害怕向后滚下山坡。害怕雾号声。害怕被你不喜欢的人拥抱。那是洛杉矶的恐惧。害怕当你随身带着很多钱或现金时被人打头。
Fear is like this. Someone like a woman that you grab ahold of her hand in going down the escalator, when of a sudden, you happens to be holding a stranger hand, not realizing that she isn't your mother, is scary. Fear that if you put too much of toilet paper in the toilet bowl, it will run over and get all over the floor and on you and on someone else, too. It would leak from upstairs to the next floor below.
恐惧是这样的。像一个女人，当你抓住她的手下自动扶梯时，突然间你抓住了陌生人的手，没意识到她不是你的母亲，这很可怕。害怕如果你在马桶里放太多的卫生纸，它会溢出来，弄得到处都是地板，溅到你和别人身上。它会从楼上漏到下一层楼。
I am afraid someday I liable to get lost inside Children's Hospital if I'm not all so familiar with that place yet. It's going to take some time to get used to it. Fearfully of that great, big, humongous Children's Hospital there ever would be to Michael's knowledge.
我害怕有一天我会因为对那个地方还不熟悉而在儿童医院迷路。需要一些时间才能习惯它。对迈克尔所知的有史以来最大、最高大的儿童医院感到恐惧。
Good that Michael's sister is driving him up there on Tuesday, January 15, 2002. Even though she's with him, she can easily get lost, too. Bad situation to tangled up in, especially if you that person has an appointment at 10:45 AM in the morning. Michael Bernard Loggins does.
迈克尔的姐姐在2002年1月15日星期二开车送他去那里很好。尽管她和他在一起，她也很容易迷路。陷入困境的糟糕情况，特别是如果你那个人在早上10:45有预约。迈克尔·伯纳德·洛金斯就有。
Michael fear that if his teacher Francis doesn't put away Michael's Top Ramen noodles up in the desk drawer, that Douglas will see it and he'll liable to want to take it. And he'll happen to eat up Michael Bernard Loggins' noodles himself. And Michael Bernard Loggins would be out of luck, but he would have to go home tonight and bring back to school another pack of noodles to eat himself, so that wouldn't ever, ever happened with that Douglas eat up noodle story.
迈克尔担心如果他的老师弗朗西斯没有把迈克尔的“出前一丁”方便面放进书桌抽屉里，道格拉斯就会看到它，并且他可能会想要拿走它。而且他可能会自己吃掉迈克尔·伯纳德·洛金斯的方便面。迈克尔·伯纳德·洛金斯就会很倒霉，但他今晚不得不回家再带一包方便面去学校自己吃，这样那种道格拉斯吃掉方便面的故事就不会再发生。
It would be very fearful if I reached up on top shelf trying to reach for a nice, thicker-covered dictionary book and not ask for help from someone, and the books come off the shelf and make lots of noises, and the people gets angry at me and don't understand that I had want help, but I were afraid to ask for it. And they'd be a jerk or a creep, as Hope tells me. And people say that I'll have to pay for the shelf, and I get in lots of trouble behind it, says Michael.
如果我伸手去够顶层的架子，试图去够一本不错的、厚皮字典书，而不向别人寻求帮助，书从架子上掉下来，发出很大的噪音，人们对我生气，而不理解我想要帮助，但我害怕要求它，那会非常可怕。他们会像霍普告诉我的那样是个混蛋或讨厌鬼。人们说我将不得不赔偿架子，我因此陷入了很多麻烦，迈克尔说。
Fear of being with a friend that you have recently met start to take you places with him, and you doesn't know him all that well. You didn't know that he were going to bring you fear and lots of trouble your way. Someone you doesn't know all that well starts to carry you in this store to buy you and him something to eat and drink.
害怕和你刚认识的朋友在一起，他开始带你去他去过的地方，而你对他了解得并不那么深。你不知道他会给你带来恐惧和很多麻烦。一个你不太了解的人开始带你去这家店，给你和他买吃的东西和喝的东西。
And all of a sudden, something very fishy starts to happen. Like for instance, your friend that you are with could be up to trouble, and whoever with him could be heading in for trouble as well, especially if a friend of yours could be bringing you trouble by stealing a big package of Oreo cookie.
突然间，一些非常可疑的事情开始发生。比如，你在一起的朋友可能会有麻烦，而和他在一起的人也可能走向麻烦，特别是如果你朋友可能会通过偷一大包奥利奥饼干给你带来麻烦。
People are fearful of me, which I wonder, is they think I'm all that terrible? Or I'm thinking that they think I'm not human at all. Because when they sit next to me, then they get back up and move away from me. I may be a stranger, but that doesn't make me a created monster or something like that.
人们对我也感到恐惧，我心想，他们觉得我很可怕吗？或者我想他们觉得我根本不是人类。因为当他们坐在我旁边时，他们会站起来离开我。我可能是一个陌生人，但这并不意味着我是一个创造出来的怪物或类似的东西。
People aren't humans. They act like ignorance dogs with their tail in back of their legs or in between their middle bodies, their legs. They don't think whose feeling they hurt at all. They just do it, no consideration for whatsoever. People don't think about how they hurt my feelings or don't give a hoot. They don't give a crap.
人们不是人类。他们像无知的狗一样行事，尾巴夹在腿中间或身体中间。他们根本不去想他们伤害了谁的感情。他们就这样做了，没有任何考虑。人们不考虑他们如何伤害我的感情，也不在乎。他们根本不在乎。
Fear of you never knowing you were going to lose your mother is very sad and scary experience you have to face and learn from. And you wonder why she has to die. I love her. And I had loved her once while she were alive, especially if she was the mother that raised you and the others through birth. And you only wish that you could have done all you can to help save her life. There going to be a worst times and hard times for Michael Bernard Loggins, and his sisters and brothers, too, especially when Mother's Day comes. Afraid this is the last thing that ever occurred to me.
害怕你永远不知道你将失去你的母亲是一种你必须面对并从中学习的非常悲伤和可怕的经历。你想知道为什么她必须死。我爱她。我曾经在她活着的时候爱过她，特别是如果她是那个通过出生抚养你和其他人的母亲。你只会希望你本可以尽你所能来帮助拯救她的生命。迈克尔·伯纳德·洛金斯，还有他的姐妹和兄弟，都将面临最糟糕和艰难的时刻，特别是在母亲节到来的时候。害怕这是我曾经发生过的最后一件事。
Excerpts from Michael Bernard Loggins' two xeroxed zines, Fears of Your Life, Parts 1 and 2 read for us by actor Tom Wright. To get your own copy of these amazing books or to find out more about the arts program where they were made, you can visit the website of Creativity Explored. That's creativityexplored.org.
摘自迈克尔·伯纳德·洛金斯的两本复印小册子，《你生活中的恐惧》第一部分和第二部分，由演员汤姆·赖特为我们朗读。要获取你自己的这些精彩书籍副本，或了解更多关于制作它们的艺术项目的信息，你可以访问“创意探索”网站。那是creativityexplored.org。
[MUSIC - "HEAVY THINGS" BY BRETT NEWSKI]
[音乐 - 布雷特·纽斯基的《沉重的事物》]
Act 3, The Best Laid Plans. So today's program is about people worrying about the future. And we thought for a change of pace, we would do this next story about people who are not worried enough about it.
第三幕，如意算盘。所以今天的节目是关于担心未来的人们的。我们想换个节奏，做这个关于担心不够的人的故事。
This is another story from our archive. It is a particular favorite. It is about this couple and the future they kind of cheerfully threw themselves towards. And after that, everything that happens to him, it's like a hand grenade they bring into their own home, pull the pin, and then wait to see what is next. And one important thing about all of this is, is that when they did this, the kind of couple they were was a really great couple.
这是我们档案中的另一个故事。它是特别的最爱。它是关于这对夫妇以及他们欢快地投身的未来。在那之后，发生在他们身上的一切，就像他们带进自己家里的一枚手榴弹，拉开销，然后等待看看接下来是什么。关于所有这些，一件重要的事情是，当他们这样做时，他们那种夫妻关系是非常棒的一对。
We were always, like, the most solid of all relationships of our friends and everything like that.
我们一直以来，就像，在我们的朋友中所有关系中最稳固的，类似那样。
Kurt Braunohler met his girlfriend on the third day of college. And in all of the ways that we think of what makes for a good relationship, I think that they were doing better than you or me or most people. They had a lot of fun together. They could talk about anything. They didn't really fight. Happy sex life.
库尔特·布劳诺勒（Kurt Braunohler）在大学的第三天遇到了他的女朋友。在所有我们认为造就良好关系的方面，我认为他们做得比你或我或大多数人都要好。他们在一起有很多乐趣。他们可以谈论任何事情。他们真的不吵架。快乐的性生活。
We really just got along very well together. We traveled well together. We were always the kind of-- we were the place that friends would come when they are having hard times, and they would stay with us. And we were kind of-- it felt, like, very adult. When even when I was 23, I felt like I'm kind of married, even though neither of us had ever, ever discussed getting married.
我们在一起相处得很好。我们一起旅行很好。我们一直那种——我们是朋友们在经历艰难时期时会来的地方，他们会和我们待在一起。我们有点——感觉，像，非常成年。甚至当我23岁时，我也觉得我有点结婚了，尽管我们俩从来没有讨论过结婚。
So what happened?
那么发生了什么？
Well, after we had both turned 30, one day I just kind of was thinking about why we had never talked about getting married. We had never, ever talked about it seriously or otherwise. And whenever anyone would ask us, we would always just kind of brush it off and say, oh, we'll get married when we have kids. That's what we'd always say.
嗯，在我们俩都过了30岁之后，有一天我只是有点在想为什么我们从来没有谈过结婚。我们从来没有认真地谈论过它，也不曾以其他方式谈论。每当有人问我们，我们总是会把它推开，说，噢，当我们有孩子时我们会结婚。我们一直这么说。
And I remember we were sitting in the living room, and it was October. And I had just said, hey, I want to talk. And I said, why do you think we haven't gotten married yet or even talked about it? And she just kind of looked at me and thought for a second. And then she said, well, I think that before we get married, we should probably sleep with other people.
我记得我们坐在客厅里，那是十月。我刚刚说，嘿，我想谈谈。我说，你觉得为什么我们还没结婚，甚至都没谈过？她只是看着我，思考了一会儿。然后她说，嗯，我认为在我们结婚之前，我们大概应该和别人睡过。
And you would imagine that that would come as a huge shock to me-- like, hit me hard. But for some reason, it kind of-- it made sense to me. I kind of was like, OK, very calmly. And I guess the reason--
你会想象那会给我带来巨大的冲击——像，狠狠地打击我。但出于某种原因，它有点——它对我来说很有意义。我有点像是，好，非常平静地。我想原因——
Wait, how did that make sense?
等等，那怎么会有意义？
I've thought a lot about this, and I think that there's a few reasons. We both had this kind of arrogant notion of our relationship-- that it could survive literally anything. That we had been together-- we had known each other our whole adult lives. We were each other's worlds. So really, I don't think we thought that we could destroy this thing.
我对此思考了很多，我认为有几个原因。我们俩对我们的关系都有这种傲慢的看法——它实际上可以经受任何事情。我们在一起——我们互相认识了我们整个成年生活。我们是彼此的世界。所以真的，我认为我们不认为我们可以摧毁这个东西。
I talked to the girlfriend who did not want to come on the radio. And she said basically she'd only had two boyfriends in her life-- her high school boyfriend, who was not a good boyfriend at all, and Kurt, who was great.
我采访了那个不想上电台的女朋友。她说基本上她一生中只有两个男朋友——她的高中男朋友，他根本不是个好男朋友，和库尔特，他是很好的。
But she met Kurt, she said, when she was 17. She was 30 when this happened. And she said that she felt like maybe she missed out on something in her 20s, experiences that other people had. And she didn't want to regret that.
但她说，她遇到库尔特时17岁。这事发生时她30岁。她说她觉得也许她在20多岁时错过了什么，其他人有过的经历。她不想后悔那个。
A warning-- I should say, before we go any further in this story, we're going to acknowledge the existence of sex between adults. Nothing explicit. Anyway, so they sat on the couch, and they talked this through.
一个警告——我应该说，在我们继续这个故事之前，我们将承认成人之间性行为的存在。没有露骨的内容。无论如何，所以他们坐在沙发上，谈论了这个。
The next part of that conversation was the logistics. Do we break up? Do I move out? Do we just do this while we're living in the same house together?
那次谈话的下一部分是后勤问题。我们分手吗？我搬出去吗？我们只是在我们住在同一个房子里时做这个吗？
And we kind of came up with this idea of borrowing this Amish concept called Rumspringa. And Rumspringa, in the Amish world, is when you're 16, you're allowed to be not Amish for two years. And then when you turn 18, you decide whether or not you come back to the fold.
我们有点想出了一个借用这个阿米什人概念的想法，叫Rumspringa（奔放期）。而在阿米什世界里，Rumspringa是当你16岁时，你被允许做两年非阿米什人。然后当你18岁时，你决定是否回到群体。
Right. And during those two years, kids get drunk. They sleep around. They try drugs.
对。在那两年里，孩子们喝醉。他们到处睡觉。他们尝试毒品。
They do lots of meth.
他们做了很多冰毒。
They do lots of stuff.
他们做了很多事。
So we were going to have-- we decided to have a Rumspringa from our relationship. And that's the other crazy thing, is that we decided that 30 days was enough. Because probably within 30 days, sleeping with other people would get that all out of our system in 30 days.
所以我们打算有——我们决定从我们的关系中来一个Rumspringa。那是另一件疯狂的事，是我们需要决定30天就够了。因为可能在30天内，和别人睡觉会在30天内把一切从我们的系统中排出。
And it turns out it's really difficult to all of a sudden become single at 31, when you've never been single for your entire life. Because all of a sudden, I'm in New York City, and I'm single. And I essentially have the emotional tools of a 17-year-old boy.
结果证明，在31岁时突然变得单身非常困难，当你一生从来没有单身过时。因为突然间，我在纽约市，我是单身的。我本质上拥有一个17岁男孩的情感工具。
Because the last time you dated was-- you were 17.
因为你最后一次约会是——你17岁。
The last time I dated, I was in a dorm room.
我最后一次约会是在宿舍里。
Yeah.
是的。
Also, it wasn't that I was just-- it wasn't like I was single in New York City. Because being single in New York City is, I think-- the majority of it is being just very lonely and being on your own, whereas this was very different. I was in a mara-- I was in a race. I was in a 30-day race to sleep with as many people as I possibly could. Because after 30 days, I was going to go back and then get married. So--
而且不仅是我只是——不像我在纽约市单身。因为在纽约市单身，我认为——它的大部分只是非常孤独和靠自己，而这个非常不同。我在一个——我在一场比赛。我在一场30天的比赛中尽可能多地与人睡觉。因为30天后，我要回到过去然后结婚。所以——
So there's a time clock ticking.
所以有一个时间钟在滴答作响。
Every single-- it was almost to the minute where I'd just be like, if I wasn't out somewhere trying to meet someone, I was like, this is wasted time. I am wasting my time right now.
每一秒——它几乎精确到分钟，我就像是，如果我没在外面试图遇到某人，我就像是，这是浪费时间。我此时此刻正在浪费我的时间。
And also because of the fact that we were both-- my girlfriend and I were both very competitive with each other, that we didn't speak during that 30 days. But I think in both of our minds, we had a competitive nature of being like, I need to sleep with more people than she does. And I think she felt the same way.
而且因为我们俩——我和我的女朋友竞争意识都很强，我们在那30天里没说话。但我认为在我们俩心中，我们都有竞争的天性，像是，我需要比她睡更多的人。而且我认为她也有同样的感觉。
That's true. She did feel that way. I asked her. So before they started the Rumspringa, they took a last romantic trip together to New Orleans over New Year's. And they had a great time. And then on January 3, after they both cried a bit, Kurt moved out for a month.
那是真的。她确实有那种感觉。我问了她。所以在他们开始Rumspringa之前，他们在新年期间去新奥尔良进行了最后一次浪漫旅行。他们玩得很开心。然后在1月3日，在他们俩都哭了一点之后，库尔特搬出去住了一个月。
So suddenly single, 31, time clock ticking, where do you start, right? Well, Kurt called this woman that he knew just a little bit and had a date on the very first or second night. He can't remember which it was.
所以突然单身，31岁，时间钟在滴答作响，你从哪里开始，对吧？好吧，库尔特打电话给这个他只认识一点点的女人，在第一天或第二天晚上就有了一个约会。他不记得是哪天了。
And at dinner, he told her the entire situation. He laid the whole thing out that he was seeing somebody. They were taking this break to sleep around. And this was a rule that he made for himself, that he was always going to be honest with any woman that he met during this month. He was going to be honest upfront.
在晚餐时，他告诉她整个情况。他摆出了整个事情，他正在看某人。他们正在休息去到处睡觉。这是他为自己制定的一个规则，他总是要对自己遇到的任何女人诚实。他要开诚布公。
And that's the weird thing. That's the thing that I still kind of, when I think back on this time, that I don't understand. I don't understand how these women that I met during that time heard this story and were like OK, let's continue with this date.
那才是奇怪的事情。那件事我仍然有点，当我回想这段时间时，我不明白。我不明白这些我在那段时间遇到的女人怎么听到这个故事，像是好吧，让我们继续这个约会。
Well, what would they say?
嗯，她们会说什么？
I think most of them-- the overwhelming response was like, wow? And I can't believe you're telling me this.
我认为她们大多数人——压倒性的回应像是，哇？我不相信你告诉我这个。
Kurt was staying on a futon on a friend's living room floor for the month in this apartment where there was no door between the living room and the bedroom where his friend was sleeping. And he brought this woman back on the first date, and they made out a little bit. And then they set another date.
库尔特在那一个月里住在朋友客厅地板的折叠沙发上，在那间公寓里，客厅和朋友睡觉的卧室之间没有门。他在第一次约会时就把这个女人带回来，她们做了一些亲热。然后她们又定了另一个约会。
I think it was probably for the next night or the night after, something like that.
我想可能是第二天晚上或第二天晚上之后，类似那样。
And what happens?
然后发生了什么？
What do you mean? What happens on the date?
你是什么意思？约会上发生了什么？
I guess I mean, do you sleep with her? Since the whole point of this story is you're trying to sleep with women.
我想我是说，你和她睡了吗？既然这个故事的全部意义在于你正试图与女人睡觉。
Yes, yes, yes.
是的，是的，是的。
I mean, suddenly I felt very modest about asking, but yeah, no, did you--
我是说，我突然对询问感到非常羞涩，但是是的，不，你——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yes, we ended up sleeping together.
是的，我们最后睡在一起了。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah. It was amazing. It was-- yeah, it totally turned my head around. It really did feel like having experiences I would imagine I would have had as a teenager, where sex was this very powerful thing, and it kind of overwhelmed you.
是的。这太棒了。这——是的，它完全改变了我的想法。它真的感觉像拥有我想象中作为青少年时会有的经历，那时性是一个非常有力量的东西，它有点压倒了你。
A day or two after that, he picks up a woman at a bar, something he had never done before in his life, and he goes home with her. And from there, he's off and running. But remember, he has the emotional tools of a 17-year-old.
那之后一两天，他在酒吧遇到了一个女人，这是他一生中从未做过的事，他带她回了家。从那里开始，他出发了。但记住，他有17岁的情感工具。
I was emotionally getting involved with these women. And that was against one of our rules that we had come up with. My girlfriend and I had had a rule saying, no relationships. We don't get into relationships with people. We're just going to go out and sleep with people to see what it's like.
我在情感上介入了这些女人。那违背了我们想出的规则之一。我和我的女朋友有一个规则说，没有关系。我们不和人建立关系。我们只是打算出去，与人睡觉，看看是什么样子。
Oh, I see. And then-- but you didn't actually know how to just go out and sleep with somebody without getting emotionally involved.
哦，我明白了。然后——但你实际上不知道如何只是出去，与某人睡觉而不陷入情感。
Not at all. I mean, the first date I went on, I immediately was head over heels for her. And I knew her for six hours.
根本不知道。我去的第一次约会，我立刻为她神魂颠倒。我认识她六个小时。
And I didn't know how to date. I didn't know how to date casually. So what I really was doing was just getting involved-- I was acting like a person who had been in a 13-year relationship with these women that I had just met.
而且我不知道如何约会。我不知道如何随心所欲地约会。所以我真正做的是只是介入——我像一个与这些我刚认识的女人有过13年关系的人一样行事。
How does that mean? What do you mean?
那意味着什么？你是什么意思？
Immediately holding hands. I remember that my impulse would be to say "I love you" during sex. [LAUGHS] That would be my impulse, because that's the only way I was used to having sex.
立刻牵手。我记得我的冲动是说“我爱你”在性爱期间。[笑] 那是我的冲动，因为那是我就习惯有的性爱的唯一方式。
And I remember the first time that I did end up having sex, I started to say "I love you," and then just kind of swallowed it and made it seem like I was coughing. [LAUGHS] And that didn't happen just once.
而且我记得我第一次最后发生性关系时，我开始说“我爱你”，然后只是有点吞下了它，让它看起来好像我在咳嗽。[笑] 那并没有只发生一次。
Kurt says it was just a month of incredibly intense feelings. He'd feel this crazy elation, or he would find himself walking down the street weeping. The girlfriend told me that she, meanwhile, was having escapades of her own. She'd be out all night, drinking and dancing, going to exclusive clubs with Mexican high rollers, doing crazy things with European tourists. It was just what she wanted, actually.
库尔特说这是一个月极其强烈的感觉。他会感到这种疯狂的兴高采烈，或者他会发现自己在街上哭泣。女朋友告诉我，她同时也有自己的冒险。她会整晚在外面，喝酒跳舞，和墨西哥高大玩家去独家俱乐部，和欧洲游客做疯狂的事。这正是她想要的，实际上。
And both of them told me that the weirdest thing about that time was that the person that they wanted to talk to most about what was going on and share it with was each other. But of course, they weren't speaking.
而且他们俩都告诉我，那段时间最奇怪的事情是，他们最想谈论正在发生什么并与对方分享的人是对方。但当然，他们没在说话。
Kurt says that one of the most amazing things to him that was kind of a revelation during that time was something-- I've never actually heard anybody talk about it aloud, but I totally related to this-- was how quickly he would find himself in the home of a complete stranger.
库尔特说对他来说那段时间最棒的事情之一，有点像是一个启示，是某件事——我从来没听说过有人大声谈论它，但我完全与此相关——是他会多快发现自己在完全陌生人的家里。
Yeah, I'd never gotten to see other people's apartments so much. That's what I kind of was fascinated by, was getting to see all these different people's apartments and seeing how everyone lives. And I love that. I love that part of it so much. You know, I was like, look at this. I'm seeing-- this is all your stuff. This is the stuff you keep on your bedside table.
是的，我从来没能看到别人的公寓这么多。那是我有点着迷的，是能看到所有这些不同人的公寓，看每个人怎么生活。而且我喜欢那个。我非常喜欢它的那一部分。你知道，我就像是，看这个。我正在看——这是你所有的东西。这是你放在床头柜上的东西。
And also having really weird experiences I never had before, like of women picking me up. I never experienced that before. I was so confused because it was a bartender. She was a bartender, so she just kept giving me free drinks. And I was like, why is this person-- why is she giving me all these free drinks?
而且也有我从来没拥有过的真正奇怪的经历，像女人带走我。我以前从来没经历过那个。我非常困惑，因为她是酒保。她是酒保，所以她一直给我免费饮料。我就像是，为什么这个人——为什么她给我所有这些免费饮料？
But it is fascinating to see, if you stay at the bar until 4:00 in the morning, and then all of a sudden-- I'd never been aware of it before, but then I started looking around me, like, oh, all these people are pairing off. Look at how this happens. I'd never been-- I've been at bars until 4:00 in the morning, but I was always-- it's all of a sudden uncovering this whole level of single life in New York City that I just had not been aware of before.
但能看到确实很迷人，如果你在酒吧一直待到凌晨4点，然后突然间——我以前从没意识到，但然后我开始环顾四周，像是，噢，所有这些人都在配对。看它是怎么发生的。我从来没被——我一直在酒吧待到凌晨4点，但我总是——这突然揭开了纽约市单身生活的整个层面，我之前没意识到。
Anyone in New York City, I feel like, can have sex any night of the week if they just followed two rules, which is stay at the bar until 4:00 in the morning and dramatically lower your standards. [LAUGHS]
我觉得在纽约市的任何人，如果他们只是遵循两个规则，一周的任何一天都能发生性关系，那就是一直待到凌晨4点，并大幅降低你的标准。[笑]
So after a month, Kurt and his girlfriend get together and talk. And they agree that a month was not enough for this. They both said it was just obvious the experiment hadn't run its course. They both wanted more time. So they decided on a second month, which then becomes the third month.
所以一个月后，库尔特和他的女朋友聚在一起交谈。他们同意一个月对于这个不够。他们俩都说很明显实验没走完它的过程。他们俩都想要更多时间。所以他们决定了第二个月，然后变成了第三个月。
And for Kurt, as time went on, it got harder and harder to stick with the rule that they had made of not getting into any relationships. He was just muddling about how to figure out how to do that. In his head, he would think, like, when is something actually a relationship?
对库尔特来说，随着时间推移，坚持他们制定的不进入任何关系的规则越来越难。他只是在搞清楚如何做到那点。在他的脑海里，他会想，像，什么时候某事实际上是一种关系？
And I think in my head, I was like, three dates. Three dates makes a relationship. That's what I defined. And so then I would try to not see people for more than three times. That was increasingly difficult.
而且我想在我的脑海里，我就像是，三次约会。三次约会构成一种关系。那是我的定义。所以然后我会尝试不看人超过三次。那是越来越难的。
It's difficult because he was giving women two opposite messages at the same time. He would tell them that he was just taking a month's break from his real relationship, and this isn't serious. But then he didn't hold back any of his feelings.
这很难，因为他同时给女人两个相反的信息。他会告诉她们他只是从他真实的关系中休息一个月，这不是认真的。但然后他没保留任何他的感觉。
What I felt like kept happening was that I would act like I wanted to be their boyfriend. And then after three dates, would just abruptly end it, with no explanation whatsoever.
我觉得一直在发生的是，我会表现得像我想成为她们的男朋友。然后三次约会后，会直接结束它，没有任何解释。
And definitely people would yell at me and call me names. And to this day, I feel horrible about that. Because I was just-- I was acting like a crazy person. I was acting like a person with absolutely no boundaries.
而且人们肯定会对我尖叫，叫我名字。直到今天，我对此感到可怕。因为我只是——我在表现得像个疯子。我在表现得像一个完全没有界限的人。
So it was hard to stop himself while it was going on. And when we talked about it, Kurt's best explanation for that was--
所以这在发生时很难停止自己。而当我们谈论它时，库尔特的最好解释是——
Well, I once had a-- when I had a dog-- when I was a kid, I had a dog. And one day, the cat knocked a five-pound bag of sugar off onto the floor. And my dog was about nine pounds. He was a toy poodle. And he ate all five pounds of sugar in one day. And then he was sick for, like, three days afterwards.
嗯，我曾经有一个——当我有一个狗时——当我小时候，我有一只狗。有一天，猫把一袋五磅的糖撞到了地板上。我的狗大约九磅。他是一只玩具贵宾犬。他一天吃了所有五磅糖。然后他病了大概三天。
But I always think about that, that day for him, how amazing that day must have been. You're eating all of that sugar and eating it, and then kind of going away from it for a little while and being like, I can't stop. When is this going to happen again? And then he just started vomiting and vomiting for three straight days. And that's how I felt, you know? I knew this was bad, but I was like, when is this ever going to happen again?
但我总是想那个，那一天对他来说，那一天肯定有多棒。你吃所有那些糖，然后把它吃掉，然后有点远离它一会儿，像是，我不能停止。这什么时候会再发生？然后他就开始呕吐，连续三天呕吐。那就是我的感觉，你知道？我知道这很坏，但我像是，这什么时候会再发生？
I asked Kurt's girlfriend if all this happened to her during the Rumspringa, too, if it was hard just to have sex without emotion entering into it at all. And she said, absolutely not. Quote, "You mean the dudes that I meet at bars or parties, whatever? Those people?" She said, I didn't tell anyone anything about my background or the situation.
我问库尔特的女朋友是否所有这些也在Rumspringa期间发生在她身上，是否很难只是发生性关系而不带入情感。她说，绝对不是。引用，“你是说我在酒吧或派对上遇到的人，不管怎样？那些人？”她说，我没告诉任何人关于我的背景或情况的任何事情。
And I asked her, wait, so you wouldn't explain, I'm on a break from a relationship? She said no, because it sounds crazy. I told her that Kurt would reveal all of that, which she knew. And she said, yeah, Kurt's way too open. But, quote, "That openness probably just made him more appealing to the ladies."
我问她，等等，所以你不会解释，我正在关系中休息？她说不，因为它听起来很疯狂。我告诉她库尔特会揭露所有那些，她知道的。她说，是的，库尔特太开放了。但，引用，“那种开放大概只会让他对女士们更有吸引力。”
By the end of three months, Kurt started to fall for this woman that he met in Australia-- and this time, really, actually fell for her in a real way. And this made him, of course, feel differently about his relationship with his girlfriend.
三个月结束时，库尔特开始爱上他在澳大利亚遇到的这个女人——这次是真的，实际上以真实的方式爱上了她。而这让他，当然，对他的女朋友的关系有了不同的感觉。
So he flew back to the States, stayed at their old apartment, and because this is the most comfortable relationship that has ever existed between two people, of course, they dealt with it all right away, very straightforward.
所以他飞回美国，留在了他们旧的公寓里，而且因为这是两个人之间存在过的最舒服的关系，当然，他们处理得很好，非常直率。
And we woke up in the morning, and we went and got brunch. And we brought it to the park, the way we'd always used to do on Saturdays. And we just sat in the park and talked. And we broke up.
我们早上醒来，我们去吃了早午餐。我们把它带到公园，就像我们以前在周六做的那样。我们只是坐在公园里谈论。我们分手了。
And that's the thing. I can't point to something that was bad about our relationship, except for knowing that I feel like it had run its course. I mean, we organically got to the point where we both thought this was a good idea.
这就是事情。我不能指出我们的关系有什么坏处，除了知道我觉得它已经走完了过程。我是说，我们有机地到达了我们俩都认为这是一个好主意的点。
This-- the Rumspringa?
这个——Rumspringa？
It's almost like the relationship had an expiration date, but we didn't know about it. And then all of a sudden, we came up with this really complicated, crazy plan to put the test down at the right place where it would break. And it broke.
它几乎像关系有一个到期日，但我们不知道它。然后突然间，我们想出了这个非常复杂、疯狂的计划在测试放下正确的地方它会断裂。它断裂了。
His old girlfriend said something similar. She said she'd probably wanted out of the relationship before the Rumspringa, but she was too scared to admit it to herself. The Rumspringa gave them a way to break up.
他的旧女朋友说了类似的事情。她说她大概在Rumspringa之前就想离开这段关系，但她太害怕承认它。Rumspringa给了他们一种分手的方式。
Kurt says he would not want to do a Rumspringa again, but he came out of this experience believing that it is important to force things to a decision with someone, and that it's healthy for any relationship to be evaluated now and then.
库尔特说他不想再做一次Rumspringa，但他从这种经历中出来相信强迫事情与某人做出决定是很重要的，并且任何关系现在和那时进行评估都是健康的。
I do have a theory now. I do have a theory about if I do get married in the future, what I think I would want to do is have an agreement that at the end of seven years, we have to get remarried in order for the marriage to continue. But at the end of seven years, it ends. And we can agree to get remarried or not get remarried.
我现在有一个理论。我有一个理论关于如果我未来结婚，我想做的是达成一个协议，在七年结束时，我们必须重新结婚为了婚姻继续。但在七年结束时，它结束。我们可以同意重新结婚或不重新结婚。
Why?
为什么？
Because then I think you get to choose. And I think it makes the relationship-- would make the relationship stronger.
因为那样我认为你得到选择。而且我认为它让关系——会让关系更强大。
I don't know what I think of that, because I think, actually, one of the things that's a comfort in marriage is that there isn't a door at seven years. And so if something is messed up in the short term, there's the comfort of knowing like, well, we made this commitment. And so we're just going to work this out.
我不知道我怎么看那个，因为我认为，实际上，婚姻中一种安慰是七年时没有门。所以如果短期内某事乱了，知道，嗯，我们做了这个承诺。所以我们只是要解决这个。
And even if tonight we're not getting along, or there's something between us doesn't feel right, you have the comfort of knowing, we've got time. We're going to figure this out. And that makes it so much easier. Because you do that through times when you hate each other's guts. You know what I mean?
即使今晚我们相处得不好，或者我们之间某事感觉不对，你有安慰知道，我们有时间。我们要解决这个。这让它容易得多。因为你通过那些你恨不得对方去死的时候那样做。你知道我的意思吗？
Of course you do, yeah.
当然你做了，是的。
And the no-escape clause, weirdly, is a bigger comfort to being married than I ever would have thought before I got married.
而无逃脱条款，奇怪地，是比我结婚前想象到的对婚姻更大的安慰。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I had never thought of it that way. I like thinking about it that way. You just see so many examples of where people don't think that way.
我从来没那样想过。我喜欢那样想。你只是看到这么多人们不那样想的例子。
But Kurt and his girlfriend feel like the Rumspringa got them where they needed to go as a couple, even if that place was different than they intended when they began the whole thing. Sometimes what you need to do next as a couple, you can't even tell what it should be. And the best you can do is hold your breath, make a guess, and jump.
但库尔特和他的女朋友觉得Rumspringa让他们到达了他们需要去的地方作为夫妻，即使那个地方不同于他们开始整个事情时打算的地方。有时候你需要做接下来作为夫妻的事情，你甚至不能分辨它应该是什么。你能做的最好的是屏住呼吸，做出猜测，然后跳。
Well, these days, Kurt Braunohler is the host of a podcast called Bananas, and he virtually hosts the long-running variety show with Kristen Schaal, Hot Tub with Kurt and Kristen, Mondays on Twitch. So that story is a few years old. And I could probably say a lot about the things that Kurt and I talk about at the end, but I will leave it at this-- these days, Kurt is married, and I'm not.
好吧，这些日子，库尔特·布劳诺勒是播客《香蕉》（Bananas）的主持人，他与克里斯汀·沙尔（Kristen Schaal）虚拟主持长期的综艺节目，《与库尔特和克里斯汀的热水澡》，每周一在Twitch上。所以那个故事是几年前的。我大概可以说很多关于库尔特和我最后谈论的事情，但我会留下它——这些日子，库尔特结婚了，而我没。
Act 4, POTUS Operandi. OK, I'll say it. I believe that children are our future. And I believe that worries for our children and their future are probably the most common worries out there. Humanity's number one worry category, top of the charts, our survey says can't be beat, generation after generation.
第四幕，总统作风。好吧，我会说。我相信孩子们是我们的未来。我相信对我们孩子和他们未来的担忧大概是最普遍的担忧。人类第一大担忧类别，图表顶部，我们的调查说不可被打败，一代又一代。
But there's a whole other class of thoughts about our kids' futures that are less-- I don't know. They're not worry, exactly. They're more just like curiosity. 10 years ago, one of our producers back then, Jonathan Menjivar, talked about both those feelings, the curiosity and the worry, on our show.
但还有一整类关于我们孩子未来的想法没那么——我不知道。它们不是担心，完全。它们更多只是好奇。10年前，我们当时的制片人之一，乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar），在我们的节目上谈论了这两种感觉，好奇心和担心。
POTUS will have dark wavy hair. Her eyes will be brown, unless they're green, or maybe hazel. She will have full lips. She will not be tall, which is a nice way of saying that she might be short.
总统会有深色的波浪发。她的眼睛是棕色的，除非它们是绿色的，或者大概是榛色的。她会有丰满的嘴唇。她不会很高，这是一个很好的方式说她可能会很矮。
Because of this fact, POTUS will not like going to concerts because, like my wife Hillary, she'll only be able to see the backs of other people's heads and that spot on a person's back between their shoulder blades. Someday when she touches that spot on a person she loves, it will feel oddly familiar and comforting. Because all her life, while standing in line at the swings or waiting for a cashier to ring up her milk, she will have looked at that spot on other people.
由于这个事实，总统不会喜欢去音乐会，因为，像我的妻子希拉里，她只能看到别人的头的后面和那个人后背在肩胛骨之间的地方。有一天当她摸到她爱的人身上的那个点时，它会感觉奇怪地熟悉和安慰。因为她一生中，当站在秋千队里时或等待收银员算她的奶费时，她会一直看着别人身上的那个点。
Because she will be our daughter, POTUS will like chocolate ice cream and enjoy puns. She will need glasses by third grade.
因为她会是我们的女儿，总统会喜欢巧克力冰淇淋和享受双关语。她会在三年级前需要眼镜。
POTUS, I should explain, is what Hillary and I have taken to calling the little girl Hillary will give birth to in 2010. Calling our kid "it" only felt right for about a week or two. So we brainstormed baby code names one night in bed.
总统，我应该解释，是我们希拉里和我在2010年希拉里将生下的小女孩开始称呼。称呼我们的孩子“它”只有大约一周或两周感觉对。所以我们一天晚上在床上头脑风暴婴儿代号。
Hillary thought the name should be something like that opening scene in the West Wing pilot, the one where Rob Lowe walks out of the shower, and a woman in underwear and a men's dress shirt reads from his pager, "POTUS in a bicycle accident." Hillary said our code name should pop like that. But we couldn't think of anything as cool as POTUS, so we just stole it.
希拉里认为名字应该是类似那场《白宫风云》（West Wing）首映式的那个场景，罗伯·洛（Rob Lowe）走出淋浴，和一个穿着内衣和男人礼服衬衫的女人从他的传呼机读，“总统发生自行车事故”。希拉里说我们的代号应该像那样弹出。但我们不能想到任何像总统一样酷的东西，所以我们只是偷了它。
I worried that while POTUS was still nothing more than cells splitting into other cells that we might be setting unachievable expectations by naming her the acronym the Secret Service used to refer to the President of the United States. When people find out you're having a baby, they predict all kinds of things about the child you'll have. But I wanted to let POTUS tell us who she was, so I tried to cling mostly to the facts.
我担心当总统还不是什么超过分裂成其他细胞的细胞时，我们可能会通过把她命名为特勤局用来指代美国总统的缩写来设定无法实现的高度期望。当人们发现你要有个孩子时，他们预测你将会有什么样的孩子。但我想要让总统告诉我们她是谁，所以我尝试 cling 大多 cling 到事实。
20 weeks into Hillary's pregnancy, we went in for an ultrasound. Our ultrasound technician looked like Kate from Jon & Kate Plus 8 in scrubs. She had that crazy hairdo and everything. We asked if she could tell the gender of the baby. And she said, it's a girl. She said it with the same level of enthusiasm I used to tell Hillary that we got a gas bill in the mail.
希拉里的怀孕20周，我们进去进行超声检查。我们的超声技术员看起来像穿着刷手服的《强与凯特+8》（Jon & Kate Plus 8）里的凯特（Kate）。她有那个疯狂的发型和所有东西。我们问她是否能分辨婴儿的性别。她说，是女孩。她用同样程度的热情说出它，我过去告诉希拉里我们收到邮件里的煤气费单时的那种热情。
Knowing that POTUS was a girl meant that now there was a shape to the mystery. The ultrasound gave us the lines of a coloring book, and we couldn't help but fill them in. Hillary remembered all the stuff about dominant and recessive genes that I slept through in my high school biology class.
知道总统是女孩意味着现在神秘有了一个形状。超声波给了我们涂色书的线条，我们不禁填充它们。希拉里记得所有关于我在高中生物课上睡过头的显性基因和隐性基因的东西。
And we thought about our friend Michelle, a biologist who spends her days working with fruit fly genes. I don't really understand what it is she does exactly, except that it has something to do with diabetes. And this summer, when I was having a fruit fly infestation, she didn't have any suggestions for how I could capture or kill them.
我们想到了我们的朋友米歇尔，一位生物学家，她花天工作水果蝇基因。我并不真正理解她确切做什么，除了它与糖尿病有关。而且这个夏天，当我遭遇果蝇侵扰时，她没有任何建议关于我如何能捕捉或杀死它们。
I thought maybe Michelle could help us figure out what POTUS might look like. She said she'd do her best, but that this stuff was more complicated in humans than what I was imagining. She also told me that there was a great paper published in Science recently about the genetics of dog coats, and that if we were breeding a dog instead of a little girl, she could be really helpful.
我想大概米歇尔能帮助我们弄清楚总统看起来可能像什么。她说她会尽力，但这东西在人类身上比我想象的更复杂。她还告诉我，《科学》（Science）最近发表了一篇关于狗皮毛遗传学的精彩论文，如果我们是在培育一只狗而不是一个小女孩，她会非常有帮助。
So Michelle came over to our house, and in exchange for lasagna and a beer, she sat with me and drew Punnett squares, those little squares divided into four smaller squares that are supposed to help you figure out what traits win over others. Michelle was willing to commit to a few things, like the fact that POTUS will likely have dark hair.
所以米歇尔来到我们家，为了换取烤宽面条和啤酒，她和我坐在一起画旁尼特方格（Punnett squares），那些分成四个小方格的小方格旨在帮助你弄清楚什么特征赢过其他。米歇尔愿意承诺几件事，比如总统可能拥有深色头发的事实。
But really, she said, even if she was able to study me and Hillary in a lab, she couldn't tell us with any certainty what our baby will look like. Because unlike dogs, humans haven't been bred for certain traits, so there's really no way of knowing what green eyes may be hiding in my genes.
但真的，她说，即使她能在实验室研究我和希拉里，她不能确定地告诉我们我们的婴儿看起来像什么。因为不像狗，人类没有被培育特定特征，所以真的没有办法知道绿色眼睛可能隐藏在我的基因中。
Mostly, she said, the whole dominant/recessive thing could help us figure out dopey stuff. Like, for instance, now we know that POTUS will have unattached earlobes and be able to impress her friends with her ability to roll her tongue like a taco.
大多，她说，整个显性/隐性东西能帮助我们弄清楚笨东西。比如，例如，现在我们知道总统会有未连接的耳垂，并将能够用她滚舌头成塔可饼的能力给她的朋友留下深刻印象。
A few months ago, not long after we found out that POTUS was a girl, I was riding my bike home from work. The traffic was heavy, so I was going pretty slow. I looked to my right and noticed a girl on the sidewalk looking at me, staring, really. She looked like she was in her early 20s, and she had her auburn hair tied in a thick braid that swung over her right shoulder.
几个月前，在我们发现总统是女孩后不久，我骑车从工作回家。交通拥堵，所以我走得很慢。我向右看，注意到人行道上的一个女孩看着我，盯着，真的。她看起来像在20多岁，她有她的赤褐色头发绑在一个厚辫子里，摇摆在她的右肩上。
I can't remember if she was wearing glasses, but I know she was wearing a dress and holding a petition clipboard in her right hand. If skin was made of Play-Doh, hers is what you would get if you forever mixed the Hillary color with the Jonathan one. I couldn't tell you if it was that or the way she looked at me intently that's to blame, but I stared back. And for a split second, I thought she might be POTUS all grown up.
我不记得她是否戴着眼镜，但我知道她穿着裙子，右手拿着一个请愿剪贴板。如果皮肤是培乐多（Play-Doh）做的，她的就是你永远混合希拉里颜色和乔纳森颜色时会得到的。我不能告诉你如果是那个还是她专注看着我的方式是罪魁祸首，但我盯着回去。有一瞬间，我以为她可能是长大后的总统。
I wanted to ask her so much, how was school? You live around here? What do you like more, seeing fireflies for the first time in the summer or the first fat snowflakes of winter? Really, though, every question was some variation on the one big question I'll try my whole life to make POTUS answer yes to-- are you happy? It's also, I realize, a question I can't predict the answer to.
我想问她太多，学校怎么样？你住在附近吗？你喜欢什么多，夏天第一次看到萤火虫还是冬天的第一场大雪花？真的，虽然，每个问题都是我在我一生中会尝试让总统回答“是”的那个大问题的一些变化——你快乐吗？它也是，我意识到，一个我不能预测答案的问题。
Jonathan Menjivar. These days, he's making shows at Pineapple Street Studios. His daughter Sasha is now 10 years old in 5th grade, really into playing the drums, and running for school treasurer.
乔纳森·门吉瓦尔。这些日子，他在菠萝街工作室（Pineapple Street Studios）制作节目。他的女儿萨沙（Sasha）现在10岁，在5年级，真正喜欢打鼓，并竞选学校财务主管。
[MUSIC - "EVERYTHING RIGHT IS WRONG AGAIN," BY THEY MIGHT BE GIANTS]
[音乐 - “一切对的都是错的”，由他们可能是巨人（They Might Be Giants）]
Our program was produced today by Bim Adewunmi and me. The people who put together today's show include Elna Baker, Dana Chivvis, Aviva DeKornfeld, Noor Gill, Chana Jaffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Alyssa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor, Sara Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们的节目今天由比姆·阿德温米（Bim Adewunmi）和我制作。把今天节目放在一起的人包括埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）、达纳·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）、努尔·吉尔（Noor Gill）、查纳·贾菲-沃尔特（Chana Jaffe-Walt）、赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）、莉娜·米西齐斯（Lina Misitzis）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、艾丽莎·希普（Alyssa Shipp）、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和戴安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的总编辑，萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sara Abdurrahman）。我们的高级编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。
Special thanks today to Sahil Mehrotra, Dr. Daniel A. Smith, Casey Morell, and Steve Schale. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos and all kinds of other stuff there. thisamericanlife.org.
今天特别感谢萨希尔·梅赫罗特拉（Sahil Mehrotra）、丹尼尔·A·史密斯博士（Dr. Daniel A. Smith）、凯西·莫雷尔（Casey Morell）和史蒂夫·斯凯尔（Steve Schale）。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，那里你可以免费听我们超过700集的档案。还有，那里有视频和所有其他种类的东西。thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. His new enemy? February. He'll tell you himself, very shifty month. It's supposed to be 28 days long. You never know it's going to stick around an extra day and refuse the peaceful transfer of power into March.
《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所（Public Radio Exchange）送到公共广播电台。感谢，一如既往，我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。他的新敌人？二月。他会自己告诉你，非常狡猾的月份。它应该有28天长。你永远不知道它会坚持额外的一天并拒绝和平移交权力进入三月。
We all remember. We all remember what happened in 2016. We remember all of it, and so nobody trusts it anymore.
我们都记得。我们都记得2016年发生了什么。我们记得所有这些，所以没人再信任它了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "EVERYTHING RIGHT IS WRONG AGAIN," BY THEY MIGHT BE GIANTS]
[音乐 - “一切对的都是错的”，由他们可能是巨人（They Might Be Giants）]